yeah welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game for change enced Lutha to
176 with the French flag let's save the
bank oh um benoni know benoni yay
against the Benoni you have fun quite a
wide choice this is a line that I quite
often get from the age three things
Indian black usually takes and place a
rookie a check this recently uh-huh this
recently had been tested in a game this
it takes with meraz which playing black
don't really understand p 5 p.m.
it takes D eat XD and what exactly is
the compensation
alright so you will probably give ruki a
check otherwise I even understand it
less so
yeah okay I can play various moves
actually I kept like Bishop e3 you mmm
maybe 90 form or I can't even move the
king of a one King everyone it's not too
not bad very often you can just just
play g3 or g4 play king g to the next
and everything's fine Bishop e2 is also
a possibility just serve the simple move
not bad probably but I actually like
that one after 94 for example I can't
play Quincy to I can fight fight for the
foursquare after Bishop e2 94 he gets
active with the snide and I'm not a I'm
not able to easily retreat to see three
so king of one tries to control you for
better and as mentioned i always have
the idea to play a g4 if there's also a
line if black doesn't blunder or
whatever this pawn with b5 and just
takes on d5 and gives the check so this
position without be 595 even then King
f1 is a pretty decent move so a 6 I just
returned so I know I have I simply have
this position I mentioned with black
having lost the the B porn for nothing
okay 97 so just g3 or g4 g4 quite often
now it's not bad at all winning winning
space but to keep it simple I can just
then get the King to g2
yeah okay now white just needs to be
precise than none then why should win
this what I'm of course need to make
sure of is that I get my queen side
developed properly the rukon be eight
and the bishop on g7 make it somewhat
difficult to play be three but the
problem with this be five movies also
that the poor it's not just a pawn it
makes the queenside you're completely
rigid there are no no way there's no way
to to open up the Queen side and it it
is a very safe position here I only kept
hard to understand right age 70 I don't
know well what I want to do is I want to
get out of this diagonal and play just
play be three which secures the
queenside perfectly and that I can
actually start to to trade down pieces
to a to winning end game
b3 immediately I was possible as well
but I've got time m that's absolutely no
no need to rush with anything here
the question is still what smile on my
best setup for the pieces Bishop here
for example on c1 there are there many
possible ideas you can put it on f4d to
or be to be to it's not a bad spot i
mean the long diagonal maybe i can add
one point exchange those pieces Bishop
f4 as always keeping some pressure on on
the d6 porn ok now he is playing 95 how
to go about that now maybe 94 make sure
it looks good this is why be three at
droopy one as I'm as a good idea if he
now takes with the part i can i can take
one c5 when maybe he is doing that
anyway but hmm yeah maybe he should
actually be should be five or so
the apple should be five is very Airy um
yeah how to put it it doesn't really
give white any anything to think about
can just continue to trade down the pawn
takes Knight see 5 f-5 I don't know
maybe some way to screw this up all
right um just taken yeah let's just take
this and now mm f4 f4 and g4 and I can
play a 5
you know I can just put put roofs on the
hell should be a simple at Knight to f3
to get to the get to a good spot IAM now
I'm each form hey if I thing yeah
probably probably he will take him on g3
giving up the exchange yeah but I can
just recapture this is much simpler than
taking on e5 if he takes only one now um
it's just them this pretty helpless
position upon down and full of
weaknesses and um I don't know I don't
want to take and allow FIV for stuff
like that I can just continue without
grabbing a gripping the material or
let's say I only want to grab it if I'm
sure that it's actually winning I can
Queen to h6 it's a good good idea
yeah I don't know maybe I should really
take it at some point
I'd like to isn't that some way now to
to use the pin
I take 85 with the rook with the rook
takes Queen c3 then-rookie one yeah I
will get you five this is this is good
I'm sorry mmm yeah this is good again
t5i take with the rock not with the
night because in this position here with
rook e1 coming I'm attacking it three
times which I cannot accomplish with
them after taking with the night just
one time for shorty I will just get a
fire you cannot prevent it and then have
two parts up and still dominate
yeah Ruby five next pretty much whatever
is doing
yeah he needs to take now and after
Queen takes it's an end game with two
pawns
ok this is also possibility of course
check
yeah no need to look for anything fancy
here just trade down to the to the
winning end game ok so it doesn't want
to trade more understandably maybe h4
looks good fixing the Ponzi on g 6 + f5
the good positional move it it also
allows an IG 5 which I wanted to play
now um does it have any drawbacks no
probably not Knight g4 I can play Queen
e6 check check and then we should be two
to take the night back
yep threatening to take it probably
Knight f6 and then I'll play in Bishop
f3 and tending d6 i won why not show up
t6 t6 needs needs to be timed properly
but it's no no need to to rush anything
here can also um think about this night
it's not so sure that the night is so
well placed ERG 5r well maybe maybe it
is 96 coming hmm and I need to after
Knight f6 maybe just Queen five and 96
very strong yeah
clearing this square e 6 for the night
so how to how to play this now there are
some direct way g-form maybe
he doesn't have a check or anything
g-form intending g5 can just take now
here is using a pin or is there
something better I probably not
dad's opinion on the night very hard to
to move for black hair without losing
materials straight away
yeah okay but still there's no no way to
to mate h5 may be okay Maddie can take
on e6 don't want that night g or my dear
forest yeah many many good moves
yeah of course i'd like to find a mate
first mate but that's maybe not possible
sometimes it looks dreadful but there is
no maid ok I'd like to play we should be
6 cm
maybe there was a major i didn't i
didn't find one okay a check here he's
in the same isn't the same ugly paycheck
as before King g7 I even have night air
h5 by at age five mmm so he needs to go
to h seven and then probably just a
night h5 now right h5 Knight takes Queen
d8 is only it can only has a check done
on that form a single check
oh he's taking his sweet time
black resigned yeah yeah it's simple
simple you cannot play be fire it's just
giving away a pawn for zip for the pen
tip was just nothing just for
comparison's sake if you look at this p5
is what you play the normal this is this
one check looky a check and here the
best movies Bishop e3 but there's also
king of one that's not a bad move and if
you now compared to the game we played
be fine if I took takes takes root ahead
can you have one and then then he played
a six I drop back this exactly the same
position as before there's only the b7
thorn missing and this position with the
b7 point is so probably a still slightly
more comfortable for white and just with
the poor missing it it amounts to to a
win basically if you don't screw up or
blunder piece or something it's it's
just a pawn and it's um it's also the
possibility of playing b5 is always
somehow in this position and without the
B porn obviously there's none of that
yeah here pretty quickly it was apparent
that black doesn't have have any plane
for this I wasn't I was a bit more
concerned about this here I mean not
overly worried but let's say f-5e form
for example if I take here he maybe has
the possibility to to get those moves in
and this night I didn't know it doesn't
have a good return square there's not
there's no objective compensation but
maybe you can get try to stir up some
trouble I actually would have thought
about not taking on c5 maybe age for 95
or something I don't know but probably
taking us is the best
also because after move like that
there's always this possibility are to
return upon it's it's it's not not great
for blanket but I was I was more
concerned about that because here it's
simply a position where there's no
counter play at all yeah but here I just
didn't want to take I mean I can but
like this here let's say here and then
Queen to e5 Knight f6 there's there's
probably no play no real play but it
wasn't it necessary this way it was a
good control IDM winning the e5 pawn was
just needing to pretty simple and game
win yeah in general of this this benoni
is so it's not too too great for black
having some the problem is that after
this dis capture here if white was would
be am obliged to take with the C porn we
would transpose into the modern main
line of the modern Benoni which of
course is a very valid to try for wild
for an advantage probably he also has
one but not not a great one like for
example can play b5 here which is a
correct sacrifice very complicated stuff
I don't want to get into details but the
real problem of this move water is not
the modern benoni but really the sea
takes d5 wear black eight we should be
three suffers a bit from this slightly
um inferior structure with the d6 on
being weakness white having the space
and it's it's not a terrible position
for
I'm not saying that but it's if you play
the Benoni you actually usually try to
get some activity going and this is just
slightly passive and very often a very f
join us task of defense for black also
there's always the somewhat bad end game
looming over your head with you have
some exchanges and you suffer from this
lack of space alright yeah thanks for
watching this game